Also, about a low or no histamine diet, should I be taking the aloevia immune aloe supplement?
I think it is a histamine inducer, but I'm not sure.
No, the aloevia immune is not a histamine inducer, so you're fine taking that supplement.
So there's no negatives about taking the aloevia immune.
It's not going to produce any more histamine.
We'll produce histamine in the gut is food sensitivities.
So what will produce histamine?
So histamine is an initial immune inducer when there is some some antigen that's present.
So if there's an antigen that's present, your body will make histamine.
So let's say pollen in the air.
You breathe it in, it's irritating the tissue, it's inducing what's called a cytokine reaction,
and it's going to produce a histamine reaction.
Then histamine and these inducible, what are called immune inducible cytokines,
stimulated immune response against that pathogen.
Well, of course, pollen can't be killed, so you just produce histamine.
Now normal people, why don't I don't react to pollen in the air because they don't have
issues with it mainly because of genetic reasons.
So people that have asthma have typically a lot of H&MT defects and other histamine clearing gene
defects. You've seen a lot of above your genetic profile.
So people that have a lot of defects are that they don't clear histamine
like someone who doesn't have those defects and then they don't have issues with pollen and such.
So they need to support that somehow.
Now from a medical standpoint, they're just on a histamine drug, but if you're trying to stay away
from it, it has to be drugs, other side effects, you're taking these types of products.
So these are the clear hist and the histamine scavenger. Now if you're getting a lot of inflammation
in the gut with things that you're eating, then you use the histic clear. But you don't just jump
to that too. We want to find out why is there something that's inducing histamine in the gut and
almost always in the gut that things that will induce histamines are if you have antibodies
two different food proteins, or peptides, harsh parts of proteins. So you have antibodies to
food peptides and proteins. Every time you eat that, you're going to produce this histamine reaction,
this inflammatory reaction. You end up with this huge inflammatory gut issue.
It also affects your brain the same way. So testing food antibodies can be helpful.
And how would you test that? You test that with Cyrex testing. And there's a whole bunch of
information on Cyrex 2, Cyrex 3x and Cyrex 10. That's Cyrex array 2, 3x and 10. A whole bunch of
information on that in the chronic disease and autoimmune course. But if you're having those kind of
gut issues, it's good to test for that. Remember, when I'm testing you for food, I'm testing only
for cancer drivers. I'm not testing for food sensitivities. The only way to test for food sensitivities
is to do a blood test CPM antibodies to different food peptides.